waka waka waka sta iniziando live
iniziata oggi la ga non so perché mi
laga il computer o fuori e poi quali e
seven
wow con baccani time
thank you thank you
fuori io poi anne waters allen
io poi ciao amici io non vedo niente non
so che la stessa si perchè non vedo la
macchina che è successo oggi che è
successo oggi a youtube che è successo
in sé ma manco io mi vedo a ma perché
non c'è aperto bsa potrebbe essere
quello il problema
a sori riavvio
ok ho aggiustato si vede un'altra
quotidien quali sl e thank you buy price
amici allora allora allora come state
sentite vi devo dire 23 robe nuove che
vi spiego adesso dico allora ho iniziato
ho attivato le gli abbonamenti gli
abbonamenti sul canale però devo ancora
gestirli bene quindi deve inserire i
badge nuovi e le voci nuove
dalla prossima live dalla prossima nike
ve lo spiego bene come funzionano
funzione di abbonamenti eccetera diciamo
che per gli abbonamenti del canale che
ci sono ci sono dei blues ovvero chi si
abbona a 99 centesimi al mese a tipo le
voci budget e poi ci sono i vari premi
che ti sbloccano altre cose va bene
adesso devo che devo ancora capire bene
come come gestirle perché no no no non
ho ancora il board vorrei che quando c'è
un abbonamento nuovo vorrei ci fosse la
tipo come quando c'è una donazione no
quindi devo devo attivare tutte queste
cose va beh chissenefrega chi se ne
frega l'importante è averla attivate poi
dalla prossima live metto a posto tutto
ok
perché ancora non devo farlo vediamo se
funziona l'audio sentiamo se funziona
questo l'audio funziona una meraviglia
avete un sacco di abbonati ragazzi io vi
ringrazio e vi faccio sapere meglio
dalla prossima live perché ogni
abbonamento ripeto a dei plus 15 zio che
vi ringrazio all'inizio nel video tutti
quanti quindi dalla prossima live
recupero tutti quelli che si sono
abbonati in questa ma funziona come
possibile ma io non ho attivato niente
come possibile
ma come ma come ragazzi non ho attivato
niente ma come come questa che è
bellissimo
guarda guarda è bellissimo cavolo
attivato che come fa funzionare
impossibile che storia ma dai ma io non
ho fatto buono lo so che strana stato
vabbè grazie amici grazie e tutti questi
che appaiono grazie non ho capito come
sia possibile
va beh io volevo strisce ed esattamente
questo devo aggiungere il latte quando
ci sia niente già posto permetto poi una
gif bella karina la prossima volta così
avviene più carino quando ci sono è
bello bella anche la frase che
ovviamente non ho scelto io però compare
bella bene
quindi dalla prossima la inventò tutte
le voci badge tutte le cagate che si
fanno per gli abbonamenti e niente basta
e vi spiego anche meglio come funziona i
bonus che ci sono ok basta da che
cominciamo allora noi dobbiamo finire
under the hill non so se lo finiamo oggi
non penso però eravamo buon punto cioè
più o meno minchia rega grazie grazie
grazie grazie cripa grazie mille grazie
a tutti bella stava di nuovo quindi non
so raga mi devo informare anche con
youtube per vedere bene come funziona
stanno stanno abbonando tutti al canale
grazie ed esagerati grazie poi vi darò i
bonus dalla prossima live è tutto ok
anche perché c'è un tipo di abbonamento
che vi da la possibilità che io vi
saluti all'inizio del video quello andrà
a ruba immagine poi ce ne sono alcuni
che la chat sarà disponibile solo per
chi si abbona ci saranno altri tanto gli
abbonamenti annoni nomi strani tipo pier
giorgio onofri olio perché ci tenevo a
questa cosa
gr grazie intanto giochiamo a novità
incredibile è questa qua penso ad
apprezzati tutti dall'ultima live under
tail adesso è fottutamente in italiano
perché sennò non vivevo più o meno male
perché sono era un casino ma fatemi
disabilitare qua premi due o invio
signori finiamolo sto under the il
maledetto finiamola porca vacca che
bello che funziona lo sa contento cavolo
largo allora eravamo rimasti che aveva
battuto papyrus siamo qua adesso in
italia non voglio godermi i dialoghi io
ho te la sei svignata anche tu per
vederla ad altri la traduzione viene da
un sito che si chiama spaghetti project
grazie spaghetti project per la
traduzione se no la mia vita sarebbe
stata una cacca perché non so tradurla
in un inglese così di altro livello
la designata anche tu per vederla giusto
cosa fico lei è la migliore vero voglio
essere proprio come lei quando sarò
grande ma chi come dire i genitori che
mi trovo qui ma chi ti conosce chi sei
questo è un fiore dell'eco di pietro
ripete l'ultima cosa che si sente
all'infinito e me l'ha già spiegato
quindi ciao suns
che c'è mai visto un tizio con due
lavori per fortuna nei lavori significa
del doppio delle pause normali fa un
salto fa un salto da grimly o e toscano
sanse toscano boiate a saperlo prima
ragazzi a gesù ragazza roba degli
abbonamenti e fighissima vi giuro che
dalla prossima live visti da tutti i
bonus che dovete avere degli abbonati
per ora non ho ancora definito bene
viene sarà un santo che tu
no va bene
divertiti ok ciao ma papa e lo stato
dove così lo scrigno no stessa norma
orca vacca attenzione pietre sono stato
bravissimo dove che devo andare lui la
madonna
[Musica]
ciao un di un da in undying come si
pronuncia andare infine un dinner ci
andai in onda in sono qua con il mio
rapporto quotidiano ricorda quello umano
perché ti ho chiamato prima se ciò
combattuto certo ovvio che si è
combattuto valorosamente cosa riguarda
la cattura beh no ci ho provato online
ma alla fine ho fallito cosa prenderai
l'anima dell'umano personalmente non dai
non c'è bisogno che gli animi neve di
vedi le dico capisco ti aiuterò come
posso andai in è giusto si dice undying
è andata giù come ho detto prima ei
andai in una beccato tranquilla undying
or cavalcava non era un muro questo no
andai non far cacate diane dain
questo potrebbe essere un problema ma
non ci ha ripensato va bene
[Musica]
meno male ero morto sono bravo andai in
bravo ancora questo ma chi è
yo yo prima della puzza hai visto il
modo in cui con cui ti stavo star ma
fissando manco in italiano so leggere
fichissimo ma più o meno sono così
geloso che combinato per ricevere la sua
attenzione a forza andiamo andiamo a
vederla fare a pezzi qualche cattivo ne
ho un senso di paura in commesso di te
ma mantieni determinazione salva online
e femmina e una femmina
andai in quando quattro semi ponte gabry
ponte si allineano in acqua e si
fioriscono ok a deve usarli per per fare
il ponte ok anche carina questa cosa
ciao ragazzi per gli abbonamenti
raga veramente v c'è poi intanto dopo li
leggo tutti dopo la pausa di leggo tutti
quelli che sono abbonati
poi dalla prossima live che definisco
bene in tutti i premi perché ve li devo
spiegare
[Musica]
porca vacca figura chi è questo è una
specie di genio della lampada mista
serpente misto a uomo muscoloso agisci
lotta usa pietà
agisci contrae contrae il bicipite aree
un contrae il doppio
aumenta il vostro attacco gara di
muscoli ok fletti di più ma vabbè
ragazzi in italiano è tutta un'altra
storia cioè del pro molto più figo in
italiano è un'altra roba
aaron aspetta la tua mossa vai contrae
contrae contrae ancora di più
[Musica]
aaron con tra il triplo aumenta il
vostro attacco bene ma non perderò
di cosa stiamo parlando contrae ancora
aaron contrae fortissimo aaron flette i
muscoli ed è nel vuoto hai vinto
ok questa era inaspettata bravo aaron
anche una volta a maurizio merluzzo che
si fa sta roba è sparito poi disattivare
di funghi se viene fatto un errore la
campana dei fiori può riportare i semi
ponte all'inizio
[Musica]
ma scusa milano ha capito a che errore
scusa non ho capito
[Musica]
scegli dovuto è un enigma le immagini
non ce lo fa così una così l'altro è
così è giusto
[Musica]
non ho capito a devo metterli tutti e
tre e quattro linee non funziona aiuto
non ho capito questa cosa
[Musica]
gli devo allineare tutti ma forse molto
spazio ma non ho mica capito sta roba
[Musica]
123 credo sia giusto lì allinea così no
eccolo eccolo che player grazie andrew
drin pronto ciao sono papyrus come ho
fatto la via del tuo numero dice ma
scusatemi se io l'ho abbassavo qua non
mi rispondeva al telefono c'è saranno
sta roba
ho chiamato ogni numero finché non ho
trovato to be allora dimmi che sta
indossando usa una chiamata erotica te
te lo chiedo per un'amica certo diceva
di averti visto indossare un cerotto
usato è vero sai d'aver indossando un
cerotto usato come gli rispondi si no
non son desto annunciato dall allora non
stand oh santo cielo tosato capito sono
tuo amico quindi mi fido di te al cento
per cento ci sentiamo nomi di qualcuno
mi dà una spiegazione del perché questo
uomo esiste però ok
tanto tempo fa i nostri esprimevano dei
desideri alle stelle nel cielo
se tu avessi superato con tutto il tuo
cuore il tuo desiderio si sarebbe
avverato
adesso tutto ciò che abbiamo sono quelle
pietre luccicanti sul soffitto stanza
dei desideri scusate ho lottato ma
hopper bagnato chi la vos i strascica
verso di te ok di lavo
che scherza raccolti una barzelletta in
cui un bimbo ha mangiato una torta senza
posate
[Musica]
eh no quella battuta e lercia fazzoletto
dog soletto punta proprio che la donna
guarda e lercia bellezza scherza la
continua barzelletta in cui un bimbo
ancora ma basta una battuta in lercia è
geniale ma perché il sapone cioè
batterista centralmente un casino sto
cercando del sanitario del sanitario di
divertimento
tocca cerchi di toccarlo tiravo fa un
balzo all'indietro
bleah
[Musica]
ok
la matex l'aveva pronuncia è un da in
non penso penso sia con la a
considerando che under the sea dice
under the e non un der tail però ok ti
lavi pulire che nei diavoli pulirti
inizia a saltellare tutto eccitato verde
vuol dire politico che sta dicendo si
guardano in mano a chi lava di lavoro ma
va a cagare tiravo nel senso che ti che
sono sul nome c'è odore di detergente
mai pulisci mi chiedi a chi lavori
pulirti inizia a saltellare tutte citato
posso chiedere già la pietà perché
risparmia ok
porca vacca guardine telescopio si
guarda il muro di assenza
guarda il muro che figata traduzione
hanno fatto anche durante il gioco
raga ma l'audio è alto mi senti cioè nel
senso l'audio del gioco compra mia voce
no perché lo sento bello sparato a ok
chi lavora geniale comunque antiche
incisioni ricoprono il numero riesce a
comprendere le parole la guerra degli
umani e dei mostri perché le mani
attaccarono certamente se prova che non
avessero nulla da temere gli umani sono
molto forti ci vorrebbe l'anima di quasi
tutti i mostri esistenti solo per
eguagliare l'anima di un solo umano ma
gli umani hanno una debolezza
ironicamente la forza della loro anima
il suo potere permette di persistere
fuori dal corpo umano anche dopo la
morte
se un mostro sconfigge un umano egli può
acquisire l'animo se mostro con un anima
umana un mosso con anima umana una
terribile bestia con i poteri
commensurabile scommetto che andai
[Musica]
nelle illustrazioni nostra creatura c'è
qualcosa di estremamente inquietante
riguarda questo disegno
quanta faq e un ascensore sta roba è una
zattera dell icann porca vacca stavo
guardati la manda in salve orca bacca
demoniaca aiuto è pazzo è pazzo è pazza
e una donna aiuto ai a chi male e va p
ai ragazzi è abbastanza incasinato
sapere stai calma calma parliamo
parliamo parliamo di cose simpatiche hai
visto che in therapy non guardarlo
demonio che palle ma dai
per cortesia sono qua dentro lining
saprà dove sono ok
porca vacca mi stai cercando
vabbè giorno mi ha ucciso
no ma no presa ha preso il mio amico
quello che è rimasto là poverino è bella
lì mi dispiace ben la panda in ma hai
sbagliato target mi ha salvato il culo
20 volte quel ragazzino personaggino
eccoti io quando dice io viva scassare
hai visto si manda in mi ha appena
toccato non mi aveva vero più la faccia
city stava anche per far del male anche
caspita che sfortuna che hai avuto
sarebbe bastato stare leggermente sulla
mia sinistra pensa che sfortuna non
proprio party sono sicuro che
incontreremo di nuovo la incontra mio
complimenti per le avrebbe tirato una
facciata per terra
chi è questo tizio che lo adoro
va bene sapere che un giorno il topo
potrebbe strada il formaggio dal
cristallo mistico ti riempie di
determinazione
è così che ha detto questo formaggio e
qui da così tanto tempo che un cristallo
magico ci è cresciuto intorno è
attaccato al tavolo spacca al tavolo
both with what a spitito il coso ma io
non ho capito ma quando ci sono ste cose
tu puoi fare degli enigmi ci vivo qua
posso prendere il topo e togliere il
formaggio l'art con questa roba non l'ho
capita ma è simpatica sapere che un
giorno al toppo potrebbe estrarre il
formaggio del cristallo mistico ti
riempi di determinazione io sono
determinato a sapere che i topi
toglieranno ciao talia sono rai a torino
really bacino
se riesco venga senti pezzoni a chitarra
immagino complimenti
fai un pezzo dedicavano io sapevo sono
alla chitarra poi iniziato a fare
youtube e non ho avuto più tempo di
respirare grazie mille stavo pensando di
cimentarmi nella vendita dei telescopi
ta soir suns e non vedo perchè non
dovresti fa generalmente per usare
questo telescopio premio faccio pagare
50mila g ma visto che ci conosciamo poi
sono gratis allora che mi dici così
telescopio si ma è farlocco suns è non
sei soddisfatto non ti preoccupare ti
rimborserò fino all'ultimo centesimo eh
beh era gratis
vabbè cos'è una stella quella lì poi
toccarla no poi mangiarla forse poi
ucciderla
no se per caso una stella ah sì tuttavia
che tengono solo sembra un unico e così
giapponesi che e morbidi che mangi come
si chiamano
senti una conversazione di passaggio
solo uno ma è piuttosto share ma ragazzi
non ho capito ma sti fiori qua che sono
[Musica]
non ho capito ti imbatti in gelatina
cosa ci devo fare che la gelatina
riecco domanda faccio io
domanda se tu agisci con del degli dei
mostri poi in incontri dello stesso tipo
devi agire ancora per fare pietà or si
ricorda della prima volta che l'hai
fatto
perché ogni volta devo fare agisci po
tipo con la gelatina possono già fare
pietà sempre sono poi riscatto la
ballerina lo prendi se ricevi le scarpe
da ballerino grazie ma perché sarà ma si
scurisce now
non ho ben capito
[Musica]
a ripetono all'infinito ciò che sento di
fiori colleghi libici sono tutti uguali
drin pronto ciao sono papyrus perché
skipper che parla quando parla mi sembra
che urli ti ricordi quando ti ho chiesto
cosa stesse asti indossando la mia amica
che voleva saperlo
la sua opinione molto assassino zza sta
parlando di andai in non tenere caro
essere umano papyrus non avrebbe mai
tradito la sua fiducia
hai detto che non sta riportando un
cerotto usato quindi ovviamente le ho
detto che stavi veramente indossando un
cerotto usato mi doveva raccontare una
bugia così ovvia ma dato che invece non
stava indossando accusato di sicuro non
ti aggredita
adesso sei assicuro è stata dura voglio
solo essere amico di tutti si papyrus
certo come darti torto
ecco tipo lui adesso posso fare ag pietà
no come non detto
e vabbè quanto flexa
mazza aaron suda freddo è una grandinata
di sudore e poi contrarre veramente di
nuovo che è rottura di tre quarti
le musiche sono bellissime la canon solo
già detto ma è bellissimo quando flexa
aiaf potrai flette i muscoli e nel vuoto
sta roba è geniale bene a il font di
papà eros si chiama papyrus proprio figo
non lo sapevo il potere di prendere le
loro anime questo è il potere di cui gli
umani avevano paura no è di lavoro per
cortesia è lavami pulisci mi verde vuol
dire pulito ragazzi non ho capito ma una
roba sporca schivo alla roba verde mi
cura proprio capito
e so che non l'avevo tipo capita però al
pieno
ok
risparmio che bellissima sta roba di
facciamo che ci muoviamo
facciamo che che cammini salve è laggiù
visto che stavi qua io sono hong jong
sun cipolla sunninghill in giapponese
onions han capito
certo ho nyon sun come non sei a cascata
è molto bello qua ti sta piacendo
eh sì anche a me il mio posto super
preferito qualcuno mi spieghi cosa
esiste a fare questa roba ciao mi chiamo
grazie mille arriverò in puglia avere
ris un bacio anche se l'acqua che si sta
diventando così bassa mi tocca stare a
sedere tutto il tempo ma ok va bene così
sempre meglio che trasferirsi in città e
vivere in una fuori affollatissimo come
successo a tutti i miei amici certo nyon
sun nella fuori è strapieno comunque
perciò anche se lo volessi io ma va bene
così capito
andai risolverà tutto quanto ho capito
me ne andrò da questo posto è però
nell'oceano capito ho capito
potresti smetterla di parlarmi ei senti
chi la stanza finisce ci vediamo in giro
da vivere a cascate qualcuno mi uccida
adesso grazie va beh
grazie ma tex thank you so much porca
vacca morta in sirena si nasconde
nell'angolo ma in qualche modo ti
incontra lo stesso agisci sorridi
conduce i sorrisi sorridi chiede a in
sirena di farti un sorriso in sirena si
fa silenziosa dall'angolo aaron fa un
cenno di approvazione parol motivo a
flettere i muscoli per cortesia a lei
attacca così devo sorridere ancora
continui a sorridere ma non succede
nulla è una tattica di rimorchio ragazzi
risari primo a salire ma non succede
niente allora consolidiamo il filo ma
che attacco stupido cia canticchia
conduci a ginevra scenario ora sei
vulnerabile agli attacchi elettrici
porca vacca e mandato non mi rimanda
[Musica]
conduce
allora niente non possiamo più condurre
va bene
[Musica]
canticchia
canticchi una ballata jazz in sirena
segue la melodia ma che porco schifo
porco in sirena sempre sentirsi molto
personaggio a cantare la sola s pietà
intanto mannaia quindi scusatemi livelli
non li sto prendendo chissenefrega dyson
serve questo potere non ai quali
certamente non è pubblicità è l'anima di
un mostro con il nostro umore la sua
anima scompare e servire computer e non
deve prendere l'anima di un nostro
vivente è solo un'eccezione l'anima di
una specie particolari mostro chiamato a
mostro bossi la linea dimostra bossi è
sufficiente è sufficientemente forte per
persistere dopo la morte anche se sopra
qualche istante numero potrebbe
assorbire quest'anima cioè non è mai
successo e adesso non accadrà mai
credi
io però una cosa che non capisco visto
gioco e che ti puoi andare in più via
no perchè questo è chiusa hicks esci c'è
un pianoforte qui lo suoni si
[Musica]
basta non ho capito bene cosa questa
roba prova una musica orecchiabile
riecheggia nel corridoio non vuoi
accompagnarla bastano solo le prime otto
ma i non serve a niente non sento
proprio nulla ma che corridoio scusa
allora che non sento niente sono scemo
io non sento nulla è una statua e
struttura ha la sua base sembrano
asciutte e piove
prego premi ne 1 all ombrello prendi tu
hai preso non fratello vera è sempre ma
che figata
al momento la statua è giusto ma chi non
prendo sulla stata sì
eccolo a eccola la musica
[Musica]
atc a ti dice popoli aspetta farmi
leggere allora z su destra z joojoo
destra z sua destra di 30 giu destra ok
zcs z aggiunge destra
[Musica]
vai a cagare non mi ricordo più
non mi ricordo niente
[Musica]
allora cerchio su destra cerchio giunge
destra cioè che su destra al cerchio
gesù destra stanno sbagliando
mi ricordo più cerchio giu de cerchio
era cerchio sul cerchio giu porca la
cerchi su destra cerchio gesù destra
cerchio su destra cerchio sul giu destra
sinistra destra
a cerchio su destra cerchio giunge mi
ricordo parco demonio cerchio giu destra
cerchio joojoo sinistra
cioè che su destra cerchio in giù giù su
no c'è chi è giù c'è che su destra
cerchio joojoo destro no a me pare tutto
ciò che già c'è anche il suo destra
cerchi aggiunge sinistra e non è nessuno
porca demonio parco forse lo devo fare
proprio all'inizio quindi certo su arca
vacca cerchio su destra cerchio giunge
destra e non va la sorella schifo ah ok
dovevo uscire rientrato ok è vero sono
sette il cartello diceva 8 sono sette
marce il castello diceva o troppo ma lo
sai perché non altro la sua strada
perché è verde
perdonami che va bene quando faremo con
ciccio un bacio very soon the la battuta
non ti prendono faceva schifo ma
sciopero ok grazie
non l'ho detto ormai l'ho fatto prova
erano io non mi ricordavo scusatemi c'è
una storia del drago è un artefatto
leggendario lo prendi si stai
trasportando troppi cani
cosa troppi cani cane fastidio che kit è
che picchia il cane posizioni che il
cane assorbe l'art
bp per il culo ma cosa vuol dire l'ho
perso c'e nel senso dovevo lasciare il
cane the fuck questa canzone molto bella
le cale no quindi vuol dire che se io
lascio se io residuo canino
no non ci credo ma basta ma perché mi
hai finito di usarlo un atmosfera
sgradevole riempie la stanza perché
lacan salata c'è ma mangia la magia casa
alata o palla da tennis fritta i tuoi ps
tornano il massimo è almeno quello
per favore a che serve sta roba
ma basta se residui canini ma guidarmi
lacan salata per favore buttiamo via
ires tica ringrazierà il cane molto
gentile
ah se vendo il residuo divento ricco a
beh allora lo tengo dai lo tengo lo
tengo dai lo tengono però non ho ben
capito il senso di st ma l'oggetto cos'è
che faceva scusatemi se avessi usato
l'oggetto ciao zio io nemmeno tu riesci
ad impugnare un ombrello e non l'ho dato
all'altro se ti fai una camminata
comunque immagino che verrò con te ma
andiamo che puoi dire a che cosa serve
to all'essere umano
io avrei dovuto se io avessi preso
l'oggetto leggendario che cosa sarebbe
servito dai ragazzi non ho parole non so
caspita online e così ganza voja de
precede prende a botte i cattivi e non
prende mai non perde mai
se fosse se fossi in essere umano me la
farei addosso ogni giorno sapendo che
non vorrebbe che sapendo che vorrebbe
farmi a pezzi a sei veramente d'aiuto a
non potevo prenderlo l'oggetto
leggendario che quindi è giusto che il
cane sia comparso no perché è insomma
una volta avevamo un progetto scolastico
non me ne frega niente
ragazzi non me ne frega basta parlare
piove basta mori quanto sarebbe fico
santa in venisse a scuola a me non me ne
frega niente muore schiacciato dalla
pioggia basta togliti non mi seguire non
so chi sei
forse non vincerebbe l'insegnante lei è
troppo ganza in poi sa segada come dici
guarda da vendere in culo alle cascine
però che figata
la smetti di seguirmi non servi non si
poteva prendere l'artefatto quindi ok
giusto così cosa stai facendo
io non so descrivere sto tizio ve lo
giuro posso prendere un ombrello
ok mi fai da te o questa sporgenza è
troppo ripida potresti farmi da gradino
da scalino provvederà andai mtv all
ombrello e sali sulle mie spalle ok se
ce l'ho preso quando non serviva più
bene adesso puoi stare lì sotto tanto
non riesce a tirar su non preoccuparti
permettono vero sempre un modo per
passare a dio ma
ma che tu dici maremma maremma aereo
guardia il dolce solo di un lontano
carlon ti riempi di determinata cosa che
mi riempie di determinazione a parte tua
sorella feel you with determination alla
fine potrebbe essere a malapena chiamata
guerra uniti gli umani erano troppo
potenti e noi non si troppo deboli
davvero non fu presa la singola anima e
un gran numero di ma si potrà notato in
polvere ma dai
quindi questa roba che c'è nei muri e la
loro che la che piazza sabazio a far
indovinare andai know how
hai rotto veramente le fa la volta in
cui ecco non chiedetemi di lasciare
pietà dan dyens e la devo combattere la
la faccio nera che fastidio st tentato
di uccidermi da quando mi ha visto
beh è facile questi aia eccolo non non
mi è anche beccato che culo aia
ma basta andai in hai rotto le
non ci credo
[Musica]
mandava in puoi farti i fatti tuoi per
cortesia che fastidio mi sa che sto
tornando indietro ragazzo sbagliato ho
sbagliato strada basta dai loschi vada
sempre per ora forse là di quale non era
di qua ragazzi aiuto
hai rotto beled ammazzo era giusto
invece parti con schifo io e le mie idee
stupidi torna indietro ecco ai hanno
preso
[Musica]
andai ma per cortesia per cortesia è
mamma mia che schivata incredibile aiuto
aiuto e difficile madonna voja de basta
andare in per favore fatto sto correndo
ma
è un vicolo cieco e un bug vicolo cieco
quindi dai ecco sono morto è stato breve
ma intenso sembrava che il rumore
provenisse da quaggiù o hai fatto una
bella caduta sembra va tutto bene
ecco alzati lory è un bel nome
grazie io mi chiamo vabbè non mi ha
detto il nome a sono cascato i fiori che
culo
ciao porca vacca e acqua questa cose qua
mucchi di spazzatura ci sono alcune
marche che riconosci tipo qui la cascata
sembra scorrere dal soffitto della
caverna fammi indovinare chi riempie di
determinazione ogni tanoh ogni tanto un
film di un pezzo di passato di
spazzatura viene trasportato questo mi
riempie di determinazione e cade
nell'avviso senza fondo di sotto questo
mi riempie di determinazione vedere
questo ciclo infinito inutili minuti la
robaccia fammi indovinare
proprio mi riempie il cuore di
determinazione
io con la sento domani mi faccio il tè
dopo il thè bevo il latte con nesquik e
porca vacca simili empi di
determinazione porca vacca se lo fa
porca vacca se lo fa una volta la mia ex
coi tacchi è cascata dentro il gli
esempi lato il tacco nel tombino quella
roba mi ha riempito di determinazione in
una maniera che non vi so spiegare
quando poi tra cerchi parcheggio ma
sembra di averlo trovato in realtà c'era
una smart parcheggiata a quello di
riempire determinazione si riempie
proprio un sacco di determinazione una
bici e riposi la tua mano sulla
bicicletta arrugginita il suo clacson e
mette un gemito di disperazione sarebbe
quello il jay nixon fu un computer
malconcio all'interno a vuoto mi riempie
di determinazione e un congelatore non è
una marca e non mostra segni di usura
dentro ci sono un paio di barrette di
cibo spaziale se ricevi cibo ed
astronauta e la questione del dvd di
unanime dei disperati segni di arti li
ricoprono i bordi sembra un normalissimo
manichino d'addestramento vuoi prenderlo
a botte no vi fissate agli occhi per
qualche istante mi riempio di
determinazione
[Musica]
pezzo di culo beni che dovevo farlo
anna ilarda ha troppa paura per
combatter milano non ci avevo voglia di
combattere contro manichino dice io sono
un fantasma che vive dentro un pupazzo
anche il mio cugino viveva dentro un
pupazzo finché non arriva sti tu quando
ci hai parlato pensa volessi farsi una
chiacchierata ma le cose che hai detto
orribili spaventosi inconcepibili hanno
spaventato via dal suo manichino umano
spaventerà la tua anima fuori dal tuo
corpo di essendo pupazzo blocca la
strada a pupazzo traghetti in project
praga me la musica è calzante
agisci pupazzo parla parli al pupazzo
guarda che non ci pare che non gli vada
lì chiacchierato nessuno né sembra
felice debole devo le regole
e vabbè è bellissima stavo musica rega a
brutti idioti attenzione a due mirati
fossero attacchi magici
ehi tu fai finta che non abbia detto
niente ricorda la magia osserva attacco
30 difesa perché è un fantasma gli
attacchi fisici falliranno ha pure
quindi non puoi sconfiggerlo neanche noi
ahia peccato perché potevo fare la
pacifista run se non avesse ammazzato i
primi parla parli al pupazzo pagano
l'iva di chiacchierare nessuno né sembra
felice
[Musica]
adatto si sta colpendo da solo
scusate un attimo ma se io magici parla
cioè praticamente quando mi si attacca
porca vacca ma colpi da yo yo milo
colpisco che i suoi stessi attacchi
capito fini va beh
[Musica]
ha chiesto tipo
un pazzo parla che ci devo farlo fare
così sì ma è un casino regalo turco
ma è un boss
che sfiga è difficilissimo colpirlo dai
mannaia che sfiga fatte colpi debole
debole debole se non stai calmo
ecco il pgt porco schifo
mamma mia che botta in faccia forte
pupazzo sta facendo cadere del cotone su
tutta la finestra di dialogo
me ne sono accorto e cotone quello è
bella la musica comunque non solo già
detto asti fatto un chilo di bamba sto
manichino comunque non vorrei dire vabbè
mazza che botta ai ragazzi stupidi
stupidi stupidi ricordate quando vi ho
detto di non sparare verso di me
beh falliti siete licenziatevi rimpiazza
tutti quanti perché a henoko cosa
attacchi adesso sì tra il mio vero
potere affidarsi alla gente che non fa
schifo lo stesso potere di marco merlino
abbastanza semplici ronzi meccanici
eni giorgio references madonna che
schiaffo pupazzi robot trovato ancora
mamma mia ragazzi
[Musica]
ha rischiato qua
a
eva donna che botta mi sono fatto
malissimo
mi hanno impossibile questo caso anche
peggio di quegli altri chi se ne importa
chi sei importa ti puoi arrendere per
favore non mi servono degli amici o dei
coltelli
ecco questi non so se le scordi rilancia
art in ice ho finito i coltelli
ma non importa ora puoi ferire me e non
posso ferire i the rimarrei a
combattermi per sempre per sempre da
sempre è morto non so cos'è sta roba ma
ti fa veramente male e io non ho capito
il senso di sta roba è stato un
combattimento molto tranquillo al
diavolo me ne vado beh è stato simpatico
un bravo ragazzo alla fine un po pazzo
la occhio che c'è scusa v o interrotti
non è vero a quest'ora fantasma di prima
non appena sono arrivato il tuo amico se
n'è andato o non sembra che vi stesse
divertendo volevo solo fare un saluto io
ragazzi ho capito veramente poco di
questa cosa però ok adesso me ne andrò
di casa se ti va di accompagnarmi fai
pure ma nessun obbligo capisco 6 degli
altri impegni va bene nessun problema
era solo l'offerta ma veramente io ti
avrei accompagnato se n'è andato eccoti
ti accompagno io sembra unico e quelli
di pacman i fantasmi casa mia così gli
anni in caso volessi vederla nel caso tu
non voglia sentire tranquillità
rassicurate ti riempi di determinazione
avevo dubbi sì dai andiamo a causa del
fantasmino poverino mi dispiace
povero cristo ciao hai davvero fatto il
fatto qua scusa io non me l'aspettavo
non è molto ma fa come se fosse casa tua
è la musica di prima in versione 8 bit
questo tra l'altro il browser del
computer e aperto su un forum di
condivisione di musica c'è geniale sta
roba tipo di sentire qualche traccia o
qualcosa del genere
poi alla mia tv ce lo shock e mi piace
guardare a volte che uomini e donne
fantasmi e donne
hai fame posso darti qualcosa da
sgranocchiare no no no no tranquillo
[Musica]
questo è un panino fantasma vorresti
provarlo si provi a vederlo sapeva
fantasma ci passi attraverso raga io io
io vi giuro che sto gioco a delle
piccolezze che di cibo sono caratelle
invece no non lo sono già delle
piccolezze che però uno non ci pensa e
fanno il gioco è fighissimo
[Musica]
bellissimo
no ragazzi io de mita tu qua io mi tatuo
qua mi rimini be mi riempio di
determinazione qua a me notato qua c'è
ve lo giuro è bellissima storia che si
riempì determinazione porca vacca i
quattro a scuola quanto mi riempivano di
determinazione da tradizione di famiglia
ti va di un insieme a ok non ho letto
cosa però fai come faccio io
va beh eccoci e cile fantasmino e
fantasmi la e fantasmi nei bollettini e
folletti
eccoci qua rimarrai giu finché sta
immobile e quindi basta che ti muova
quando vuoi alzarti immagini è stato
bello grazie prego ti hon hai bisogno di
riprendersi dopo tutto quello star
distesi ha effettivamente hai ragione io
me ne vado
grazie però signor fantasmino chiusa a
chiave io non ho capito però che una
lumaca me la vedo per qualche ragione
non puoi fare a meno di chiederti che
sapore abbia sguscia switch un grande
viaggio e ti attende di fronte a te
suisse qui ci arriva lontano allungati
oltre l'orizzonte switch swish così
sgusciò samb jol è un giocatore del
milan c'è il fantasmino pa ti vedo che
imbarazzo sarà lavora adesso volevo dire
è benvenuta la fattoria dinho ma anche
della famiglia bloc si sono l'unico
dipendente questo possono il tempo
andava a gonfie vele ma il nostro
cliente principale giorno è scomparso
adesso ci sono un tizio peloso che si fa
vivo una volta al mese sono fuori
scadenza da molto tempo per una seconda
casa
vabbè
attiva di giocare a un gioco si chiama
da lampo lumaca le lumache gareggiano e
se la lumaca gialla vince tu vinci ok
pronti vai la fa schifo la mia roma h fa
schifo non si muove
ragazzi io lo sto facendo giuro verace
ma io ero convinto che partisse tipo
anche a cannone se l'aiuto abbia
incoraggiato troppo poi la toro manca
tutta quella pressione per vincere la
propria innervosita ma va a cagare t a
rigiocare va bene perché stai prova c'è
ci provo di nuovo
a ae messori dovranno premere
velocissimo dovremmo una volta e si
ferma però fa un po schifo stato ma che
ve lo dico io non sto facendo niente
anche se così via ma le pressioni hanno
pressione fa schifo sta lumaca quindi
vabbè fine gara
avete entrambi dato il massimo vabbè
basta solo tre balle andiamo avanti
[Musica]
ragazzi andrei via facebook
determination la lumaca fisso mi vide
termine
cosa sta porta ok la adesso riesco a
prendere cose ho un bel po di roba cioè
potrebbe interessarti una posso vendere
per l'ultima volta a lui non compra
niente ove compra occhiali opachi
[Musica]
dammi la mela grazie va ben capito a che
serve
vabbè fissi hooper determination non c'è
niente ragazzi non capiscono ste robe
nelle cascate ma a cosa servono
c'è semplicemente è un bioma di cascate
e di funghi a ecco vedi stavolta il
fungo ha fatto qualcosa mi ha creato una
stanza c'era stata un percorso segreto
figo film with termine arca vacca nemico
speciale temi compare per sconfiggerti
ciao temi dai dei cereali temi temi
vuole soli cerare i temi sono così a
fava muore basta fa
macché temi ha scordato l'altro attacco
tali scenari me lo spieghi ragazze c'è
qualcuno che lo spieghi veramente
contrae con tra i muscoli a temi no ai
muscoli non sono carini mi permetto di
dissentire
ragazzi io non so che dire alla fine è
diventato aaron ma basta arafat e
mosconi nel vuoto o ragazzi geniale ma
[Musica]
ama di qua non ci posso andare parco a
demonia parco o c'è temi quali quali
benvenuta perché parla come una
bimbaminkia sono temi e feste mio amico
temi sono temi e questo perché parla non
senti qualcosa ti riempi di entrare in
azione determinata determinazione con
due ma attenzione invece temi spiegatemi
un attimo il senso di sta roba temi è un
nuovo sodo beh chiama sono d'accordo
dovresti andare al negozio tempo
tennis paga università arte è mi teme
compra in occasione migliore
vi prego compriamo gliela ti vendo la i
residui di cane è però va bene devo
vendere un miliardo raga è vero potrei
un potere
[Musica]
devo avere resi scazzi ma devo pagare
per l'università sì mi hai mai stai
offrendo di più di quello che ti offerto
io compravo i danni dei cereali the
train bellissimo cereali them 3g cerali
termini sconto uguali un g
va beh c'era l'item costosi 20 g io non
so che dirvi ma poi ci sarebbero gol del
compro quelli sconto grazie temi
severamente un'amica vera io prenderei
residuo di cane per cortesia fanno
schifo non serve a niente
[Musica]
io non so non so che dire possiamo
uscite può tornare indietro
ma cosa che ho appena visto cioè con
quella fantastica temi
cioè io non so so che dire ragazzi però
si sta rivelando di michelon e temi ai
gelatina la gelatina gelatina puoi fare
risparmi ha già subito imitato può orco
demonio porco ok non importiamo più la
gelatina che dite gelato na ha bisogno
dei suoi spazi di isab straiati gelato
nas ti sdrai zottola si sdraia
conteggiato la si illumina di immenso
minchia la era scarsissima quando era
piccola
[Musica]
pietà abbraccia che ti devo dire
dai ragazzi che palle anche neanche
diminuito la velocità quindi ora più
difficile tutti i danni in faccia ed isa
braccia al prezzo alto rispetto per lo
spazio personale poi andare a fare in
tua sorella per cortesia
io e salvo ti aspettiamo per un sushi
lietamente dagli australiani
[Musica]
ciao ciao salvo io simon è un mio amico
e pirla prove è salvo e un suo amico
centocinquantesimo è anche un mio amico
salvo adesso era solo tuo amico prima
del so che mio centocinquantesimo
tennista al mondo salvo non simone
simone 150 millesimi
io sono il setto con una racchetta io
sono l'anti tennis però quasi nuovo
saluta salvo e sì andiamo agli
australian open gioco io sono non
vinciamo mai niente comunque dove devo
andare esattamente dice questa parte era
una parte segreta
devo andare tipo di sotto dove devo
andare vai dei funghi a destra
[Musica]
2 che devo andare a destra destra ne
vada e scusate non ho visto
devo andare a destra ma non l'ho visto
non c'è una parte ho preso 8,5 in job
storia che sta minkia gen storia esiste
nella terra chiamata geostoria ma c'è
un'altra strada di qua mi sa che pirla
ok avete mai notato che salvo selick se
cambi le lettere la parola salvo esce
slavo
è che è successo spuntano dal nulla di
lago e aaron orco demonio sti 2 mila
voli sci ti prego sto sudando parla è
tutto bcp toso 1 su dall'altro pulisce
un casino un tripudio di roba
c'è un odore di stalla sottomarina aaron
contrasti muscoli e ti lavi però devi
lanciare la roba verde se non ha senso
che contrae insieme mi stanno attaccando
cia non so se avete capito il senso
porco schifo che male eh vabbè contrae
dai non ci credo mi favoriti lavo sono i
favoriti lavo disinstallo il canale di
stallo o posso posso that can salata
mangi la casa alata ci sono degli ossi
ha recuperato due ps ma che schifo
mangiati un cereali temi ma fanno schifo
c'erano i temi dai lowes mangiato 8.000
robot preso niente stato non vedo nulla
raga non vedo niente dove sto andando
vedo nulla aiuto ma dovetti lavo
[Musica]
non raga sto male cioè non vedo niente
buio pesto porco schifo porco o dico no
raga non so veramente vedendo nulla è
figure no per per pietà ti prego ti
prego lisa braccia
l'hack è male mi ammazzano queste ve lo
dico this abbraccia la
forse dovevo fare fugge saie
come ho fatto a sopravvivere con lo so
solo io ok ti lavo per favore dammi un
po di vita perché da mela non togli me
latte
[Musica]
ha pagato curarmi tantissimo tipo a
potevo mettere le scarpette da ballo
cibo mela granchio
amen
ce l'ho fatta ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazze
usciti da quella roba lì perché tutto
buio dietro di te no andai per favore è
un momento in cui non 7 sette anime
umane con il potervi sette anime umane
il nostro re raise gore dreamwork
diventerà un dinho tutto quel potere al
gore e schiere potrà finalmente
infrangere la barriera
riuscirà a riconquistare la superficie
degli agli umani e receiver loro tutta
la sofferenza il dolore che abbiamo
sopportato capisci umano questa è la tua
unica occasione per redimerti c'è di la
tua anima all astra però dal tuo corpo
ad ain ti aiuterò a combattere odio il
mio amico grazie a dio
com'è arrivato fino a quest'altro yahoo
ce l'hai fatta undying sta proprio di
fronte a te hai dei posti prima fila il
suo combattimento sono io quello
conquistato battendo un momento contro
chi sta combattente
ehi infezioni video live i genitori vero
vai vai scappa scampati alla
parlamentare un chan dell aiuto a mike e
perciò ci potessimo andare quasi dentro
ha detto che gli altri tuttavia esiste
la profezia l'angelo colui che ha visto
la superficie e gli tornerà il
sottosuolo diventerà vuoto e per quello
che si chiama d'arte perché siamo nel
sottosuolo wow
ciao ma ancora quasta questo non ti
aveva preso per le orecchie andai in mi
ha salvato la vita per non posso darti
con incontro in nulla cioè mi hai
salvato veramente la vita
io lo so che non dovrei trovarmi qui ma
vorrei chiederti una cosa di me caspita
è la prima volta che chiede una cosa del
genere
tu sei un essere umano giusto
caspita lo sapevo beh lo so adesso
voglio dire andai mi ha detto sta
lontano da quello da volo umano
quindi ecco immagino che ciò faccia di
noi dei nemici o qualcosa del genere ma
non sono prova ad esserlo diresti
qualcosa di cattivo così che possa
odiarti per favore sì questo è quello
che chiami qualcosa di cattivo mia
sorella me lo dice in continuazione
immagino devo pensarci io tu mi fai
schifo
caspita sono sono davvero una carogna me
ne andrò a casa del sor
[Musica]
io aspetta aiuto su inciampato da andai
in per cortesia auguri giulia
augurali grazie mille fai buoni non è
buona torta
cosa stai aspettando vieni qui presto
via dai tu mi hai salvato se l'è
svignata nova ti sbagli e sicuramente
per andare a cercare aiuto tornerà a
momenti
ok andrò a casa cavalca scappa parte che
non ho neanche troppo a vita quindi
andai non ce la farò mai a batterlo ma
sei ovunque che palle sette anime umane
e real gore e diventerà un dio 6 e
quante l'abbiamo acquisite finora
capisci con la tua settima e l'ultima
anima a questo mondo verrà trasformato
prima però come usanza per coloro che
riescono ad arrivare fino qui ti
racconterò la mia tra la tragica storia
del nostro popolo
tutto iniziò a molto tempo fa io mi
metto comodo no sai cosa ti dico
al diavolo orca vacca il rover ha messo
comodo perché dove quando stai per
morire
lunga è il combattimento ufficiale con
andai in questo
tu che brutta un culo che 66
intralciando le speranze i soli tutti
quanti libri di storia di altis pensavo
che gli umani fossero benevoli ma tu sei
solo una bestia senza scrupoli te ne vai
a spasso nelle caverne attaccando
chiunque ma non è vero li sto
risparmiando tutti autodifesa ma per
favore non li hai uccisi per noi non li
ho uccisi infatti precisi perché lo
trovi facile perché lo trovi divertente
credi credi sia stato divertente hanno
scoperto serie 7 quando i familiari di
persone non ritornano a casa lo trovi
divertente no messo tempo il tuo tempo è
scaduto delinquente non farei più del
male a nessuno è apparsa una guerriera
in armatura scintillante tutto il dolore
che ha inflitto ai caduti ogni speranza
ogni sogno che ha ridotto in cenere e di
farla pagare a colpi di lancia ti
mostrerò continua si possono essere
determinati andiamo vieni avanti e
finiamola
vabbè dai tempi a voci di determinazione
e facciamo affari sta qua
eccoci dunque basta fuggire ecco vi sono
ufficialmente contro andai a garda io
potrei agire con undying supplica di ci
han dan che non vuoi combattere ma non
succede niente di che sei verde non puoi
scappare a meno che tu non impari a
guardare in faccia il pericolo non
resterai un secondo non resisterà il
secondo l'altro rimane cos'è questa roba
ragazzi
[Musica]
vasto nel centro
andai fauna suplex ad un masso gigante
solo perché può risparmiare quando ho
detto guarda in faccia il pericolo
intendevo guarda verso i colpi a
non ho capito andai saltella impaziente
io sto morendo in tutto per supplica
[Musica]
ah ok
no semplicemente rivolgermi verso dc ad
andare anche i suoi attacchi sono troppo
facili
[Musica]
raga di cosa stiamo parlando
cioè non ho capito ma dai pensa i suoi
amici e colpisce il terreno con i suoi
pugni ma io non ho fatto niente lo
studioso salvati tutti quasi ci devo
aumentare il suo potere
questo devo fare
[Musica]
dice che non dai compiti si
complimentano più rapidi sempre più
rapidi dai ancora dai basta con
riscaldamento porco schifo porco mamma e
fate difficilissimo allora astro cibo
pietà ma ancora non posso credere che tu
voglia risparmiare me no vabbè
[Musica]
avendo ucciso il suo amico papyrus lei
ma io non ho ucciso papyrus io non ho
ucciso nessuno quella mia madre
all'inizio ucciso
andai supplica i sei attacchi diventano
un po meno estremi aia ford ka footbike
qui l'obiettivo è semplicemente schivare
i suoi attacchi osserva
[Musica]
madonna cosa ho fatto
supplica di ci andai anche voi solo che
siate amici si ricorda di qualcuno in
serata che diventano un po meno estremi
minchia
[Musica]
io sto continuando a supplicarlo in
teoria no giusto è questo che devo fare
no ma perché non ne sono parco no mi ha
beccato a lancia
dice dan dan che non vuoi combattere ma
non succede niente che fastidio
[Musica]
posso andarmene d'asta lotta maledetta
vi prego no mi ha fregato quello mi
saltava tac cavolo il primo vero che i
muover
non perdere la determinazione no io sono
pieni di determinazione cavolo andai
gran casino raga
porca vacca hangar da va bene quindi
come la devo fare uccido quando si rese
rosso vai su fuggi è ma non ero mai
rosso finché si perdano poi scappare a
meno che tu non impari a guardare in
faccia il pericolo ok
non sono mai rosso ragazzi però vabbè
continua a fuggire
[Musica]
no
minchia alcuni sono i schiva bili ecco
sono rosso dai fugge via barca che
fastidio
quindi devo andare lì sopra
[Musica]
a porco demonio schifoso questa lancia
via via via via via via via via via via
via pia via via pia via via via porca
vacca momento sono pieno di
determinazione
[Musica]
no ma stavolta mai fregato
perché può vada
no
ok
[Musica]
si vabbè
come fa
[Musica]
puoi fuggire per favore difficile come
ho fatto
basta quanto tempo no raga veramente
difficilissimo
[Musica]
minchia
veramente c'è gente che riesce a finire
questa roba
cioè io penso di riuscirci se mi ci
metto per c'è gente che non è proprio
così svelta coi comandi come fanno a
fini thunder tail del punto di domanda
però vabbè se ci provo 23 volte riesco
ma non so uno normale che gioca ad arte
come fa a fare questa cosa però ok
[Musica]
dai no
che brutta che madonna tutto l'amore del
mondo ma aia porco demonio porco che
male mi fa elevato 7
[Musica]
la lancia in groppa ogni volta perché
non mi sembra che sia finito il
combattimento invece no ogni volta c'è
la lancia devo stare attento e lo so
astro cibo
[Musica]
ma perché si
no fuggi fuggi sei rosso fuggi fuggi
fuggi
[Musica]
e vabbè gesù cristo di dio
madonna che culo perfetto
quando fai così al contrario boh non so
c'è infattibile
[Musica]
ecco
tutti gli ho presi tutti in faccia
praga l'ammazzo continuiamo così tutta
la vita se non se non lo ammazzo
[Musica]
sono veramente difficile c'è in un punto
difficile ammazzano
[Musica]
ma devo ammazzare per forza
era che non riesco ora mazzola marzo
[Musica]
prova a curarti di più in ora che ho
solo questo all astro cibo che l'aveva
usato già va bene proviamo l'ultima
volta lei l'ultima volta senza ucciderla
poi la uccido perché se nostra tutta la
vita
[Musica]
dai va bene dai girava li proviamo
l'ultima volta senza passarla perché
giustamente ma che poverino però se no
lo ammazzo ha senso
[Musica]
pregate che io vinca che se no devo far
fuori
[Musica]
o mi impegno io per vincere per
risparmiarla impregno giuro mi impegno
per salvarti la vita andai ti difende
dal mio prossimo porco demonio me stesso
niente la plancia me la prendo sempre in
bocca in bocca me la prendo sempre in
bocca o di meglio da fare va bene ok ok
[Musica]
ora che mi sta veramente impegnato
giorno sono field determination
[Musica]
niente la lancia la prendo sempre no ho
sbagliato porco demonio porco sbagliato
ma il fuggi fuggi
[Musica]
quando iniziano gli attacchi al
contrario mammamia rega
[Musica]
e stato molto bravo
ahia quando vado tantissimo
[Musica]
onore al sushi cosa che ha detto è
fatemi cura astro cibo non ho più niente
per recuperare ps era che in teoria
[Musica]
ok
nostra parte impossibile 1 un ps ciò un
ps un ps solo se mi prende solo morto
sono telefono ei come papà papà e russo
nel momento tu io e andai dovremo uscire
ogni tanto si va bene ti richiamo dopo
che hai fatto riuscita con me
incontriamoci a casa sua sono sicuro che
è d'accordo ma sicuro che saresti ottimi
amici e dai allo schifo porc sono
arrivato senza aiuto faccio io a top
[Musica]
mamma mia
pechino si è che hanno cade il ponte il
ponte armatura troppo calda ma non posso
arrendermi ti prendi mesi stacca il
ponte no è morta lei proprio ragazzi io
sono con un ps 1 non si legge qua uno su
36 un ps su 30 che culo se non fosse
stato per quel ps io il giorno dopo
l'avrebbe uccisa andai si è salvata per
un ps incredibile italia con e prendi un
bicchiere se bevi e preso bicchiere
d'acqua
non vorrei farlo però facciamolo dai
l'acqua ad andar si possono morto quel
ps me lo sono giocato perfetto ok ok
avevo 7 così sono venuto qui da cascate
per bere qualcosa
vabbè prende un altro se non ho capito
l'acqua evapora per il caldo anche il
bicchiere è evaporato filzi with
termination ti riempi dietro mia azienda
non ho capito ma va via o ragazzi è
stato veramente difficile c'è sto gioco
è difficile se vuoi risparmiare la gente
se la vuoi ammazzare più facile se io
ammazzando la gente sono più in grado di
far le cose invece no però facciamo la
difficilmente è faceva la parte
difficile cioè risparmia voli
c'è un laboratorio che figo ecco sopra
che c'è scusa
andai in scia tipo detto che c'era di
sicuro un umano dei dintorni
quindi tipo noi guardie reali siamo
stiamo bloccando gli ascensori per ora
ok quindi ci passano da 18 water a
questo deve per tornare indietro ti
porta tutti indietro scommetto visto che
c'era un punto uguale prima quindi ora
lasciamo stare
a
waters cos'è e troppo buio per vedere
vicino alle pareti ma è un computer
quello che sei stata un laboratorio
oddio questo qualcuno di delta rune
dettar un giorno credo o mio dio non mi
aspettavo che arrivasse così presto non
mi sono lavato
sono vestita male e tutti disordine e
limiti buondì sono la dottoressa al fis
sono scienziata reale di al gore e non
sono una dei tizi che attivi in effetti
da quando sei uscito alle rovine io ho
osservato il tuo viaggio tramite la mia
consob le due battaglie ed amicizie
tutto all'inizio volevo fermarti ma
guardare qualcuno da uno schermo ti fa
davvero tifare per lui quindi a voglio
aiutarti ora la mia conoscenza posso
facilmente google guidarti a robben
terra conosco la strada diretta per i
castori us gore beh in effetti ci sono
minuscole vino
ho costruito tempo fa costruito robot
tirato metta ton originale
originariamente lavoro sito per essere
un robot da spettacolo tipo la sala
televisivo qualcosa di simile comunque
di recente ho deciso di renderlo più
utile san giusto qualche piccola
in pratica aggiustatina qualcosa come
funzionalità di battaglia anti umano
ovviamente vedendo di arrivare subito
deciso che dovevamo rimuovere con le
funzionalità
sfortunatamente potrei aver fatto un
errore uccio microscopico e ora una
rissa e ora è un arrestabile macchina
assassina con sete di sangue umano con
un po di fortuna non lo incontreremo ok
ah sì o no o sì benvenute bellezze e
metta tutto da sola a quiz show di oggi
[Applauso]
posso confermare che sarà uno show
fantastico tutti quanti fatto un
caloroso applauso al nostro fantastico
concorrente e l'altra prima volta tesoro
nessun problema è semplice c'è solo una
regola rispondi correttamente oppure
muori piangi segnare contro le regole
iniziamo con una domanda facile
qual è il premio se rispondi
correttamente altre domande giusto
sembra che tu capisca il chris continua
piangi
[Musica]
ecco il magnifico premio qual è il nome
completo del re a scorrere moore ma che
possa uscire no adesso basta parete ora
tocca a me
di cosa sono fatti i robot metallo e
magia
[Musica]
ecco un'altra facile per te due treni in
treno a tre navi partono
contemporanemente alla stagione la
stazione emilia nazionale cioè dove ci
sono 400 ai a non contare sulla tua
vittoria guardia mosca ci sono in questo
barattolo perché ne so ma mi sembrano un
53 porco demonio
[Musica]
facciamo il gioco di memoria che
mostrare questo non crack a rana non ho
idea riesce a indovinare questa
lasceresti un fantasma certo che sì
mattina disposta lato non posso farli
partecipasse attraverso eccone una
semplice quante lettere ci sono nel nome
metato 7
[Musica]
è il momento di tirare fuori
l'artiglieria pesante nel the tip
simulator
[Musica]
cosa avresti dovuto dire però una
domanda che sicuramente sarà la risposta
[Musica]
seriamente quanto può essere presuntuoso
lo adoro e nonostante tu abbia
completamente sbagliato dovrei
conosciuti un merito
l'ho vista osservati sul suo schermo
sorridendo quando facevi progressi e
strillando quando fallì vi è sempre
sempre sussurrando sbagliato di andare
in quella direzione
al suo modo non è considerabile come
amore bene fare bene con la dottoressa
al tris che ti aiuta lo show non è un
altro spero drammatica non possiamo
andare avanti così ma penserà solo la
prima puntata nella prossima più drammi
storie d'amore più spargimenti di sangue
alla prossima tesori ok
beh è stato sicuramente interessante
anche secondo me io vado
aspetta aspetta
[Musica]
lascia che ti dia il mio numero di
telefono così magari insetti se l'aiuto
potrei dove hai preso questo cellulare
tipo vecchissimo non puoi nemmeno
messaggiare mi da un telefono nuovo
[Musica]
ecco lo migliorato un po a naomi ha
migliorato ma poi messaggi è diventato
un iphone 10 come saggiare gestire
oggetti ho messo un portachiavi jean che
ha registrato nel social network numero
uno nel sottosuolo
ora se ufficialmente amici
[Musica]
vado un attimo in bagno
io non ho parole
non ho capito dove devo andare però ok
fammi salvare la partita ragazzi
direi di fare un ciclo di pausa e poi
riparto da qua per l'ultima gli ultimi
40 minuti ok pausini
ci vediamo tra 5 minuti
se non si vede the nation
non mi piace sempre della gente che si
frusta in chat perché non torno preciso
o michael michael kors sport comunque
devo andare da undying erano rimasti che
dovevo andare da un dinner dunque
simpatico come si chiama testa matta
matmata ton ma quello lì ciao tra la
l'asso l'uomo del fiume o forse sono la
donna del fiume nonché importi molto gli
piace girare in barca venirti a me è
salito la barca se andiamo a nevischio
cosa che sta succedendo tra la lucky di
che ci sia freddo caldo conta su di me
in modo saldo va bene cosa cela pupazzo
di neve di ricordi come si scioglieva
speravamo che lei tornerà tra la la
[Musica]
andiamo a giocare i mostri umani e
scusatemi a tema dove a casa di un
dinner dai
[Musica]
sicuramente questa meta ton ma porca
vacca cos'è sta roba qua
vabbè ci sono cose che non mi spiego
dov'è la casa di un da in tal aperto
però mai ha tutto ciò è veramente figo
perché traducono tutto ciao amici
cerco casa di un da andai da ditemi dove
tanto io compro l'europa al negozio tipo
il al guanto clamorosa ti fa meno da ok
ha pure i tricipiti biscotto ok
vai compro biscotti amman proprio boom
la casa di un dai né vicino a qual è il
fantasma
[Musica]
andiamo a cascate ok va bene devo
tornare domenico non anche più dove però
kenya cascasse tanto c'è un gatto
disegnato sulla barca si cascate porca
vacca il gatto ma dei temi e il posto il
luogo alla stanza prima che della
lanterna si spenga il focus si l'ho già
trovata senza che mi dicessi la
cantilena
no ciò riflette il fantasmino st
ragazzino mi ricordo del fantasmino
e qua tipo no ok è chiusa a chiave non è
questa a casa di un daino allora noi
dove sia la casa diventa allora
chissenefrega di online
continuiamo la nostra strada
prova interna carezza carezza
all'infinito il collo si strizza ma non
ti preoccupare
ok però più che lei tornerà trallallà
vabbè prezzo mi consigli delle canzoni
[Musica]
svegliarsi la mattina prova è nuova ho
preso il nudo sanno non l'ho preso
perchè sono pieno di oggetti lo spazio e
la parete davvero piccola ampio qualche
metro
[Musica]
posso andare di qua a posso uscire dal
laboratorio per aspetta prima abbiamo
sopra
[Musica]
andiamo avanti da destra perché sarah
non hanno ne usciamo più
dunque la tipa è andata in bagno c'è da
capire il motivo l'udc è al fissa
pubblicato uno stato appena accorta che
non ho visto in dying verso sull'umano
cos'è tipo mi ha preso per una sera ha
pubblicato uno stato è tanto imbattibile
e glielo chiederò dopo lol
basta per ora devo chiamare romano per
fare per fare da guida scriviate porca
vacca bull carina passeggia in zona
agisci critica dicevo il carina che i
suoi attacchi non aiutano non aiuto ok
diceva carina che gli dietro sembra un
sacco dell'immondizia dice bull carina
che esalta che non aiutano incoraggia
dicevo carina che sta facendo un ottimo
lavoro i corpi diventano estremi ecco
non diciamo più a voi cari nas e cosa
facciamo prima ok a braccia dai
l'abbraccio più carina ti scalda il
cuore e tutto il tuo corpo la tua difesa
accada è fortissima cui carina le guance
di cui carina brillano di un calore
lucente risparmia
[Musica]
il col
al fissa pubblicato uno stato chiamerò a
minuti perché non chiami e basta
[Musica]
oggi usare il telefono non voglio farlo
ma io vi giuro non ho parole
che figata porca vacca sunda aereo si
mette in mezzo non sa non
intenzionalmente o altro avvicinati la
corteggia avvicina di corteccia dice a 0
che ha una potente barra di comando
ma che dici non gli è piaciuta sta roba
aia porca vacca ha fatto malissimo
accidentalmente ti colpisce con la sua
ala avvicinati ti avvicini a sud a roma
non troppo ai cosi verdini curano parco
schifo
[Musica]
se vicino a salutare ma non troppo
continua a fare così sì perché a meno mi
curo non è vero mi prendo un danno in
faccia che la metà basta il tipo è
contento se non era fa un avvitamento
altezzoso rivolto a te risparmio va bene
quindi io sti cosi quali uso per saltare
da una parte all'altra ok al fissa
pubblicato uno stato o magee da cinque
minuti con l'unghia sull'ultima cifra
lo sto per fare lo sto davvero per
chiamare più che forse ha riattaccato
prima che tu rispondessi io
[Musica]
ciao quindi lascia blu voglio dire qui
al fisco
il laser pronti danneggeranno se stai
fermo con gli arancio dovrai muoverti
loro e loro passa attraverso quelli ok
quindi l'ho fatto
le unghie non trovavano così da quando
andai mi ha chiamata per chiedermi nel
clima quindi posso passarci attraverso
aia a con quelle arancioni mi devo
muovere quello che non sta fermo aspetti
non c'è clima poi giù perché mi ha
chiamata cav h 9 sfiga ok procurarmi
biscotto
ai biscotti non mi curano interamente da
che sfiga il laser siano disattivati o
basta al fish al face forse si chiama o
mi ami o mio dio dimenticato di spiegare
dove deve andare in b carina di me è una
foto di un cestino con applicati molti
filtri rosa e glitterati qui al fis la
porta nord sarà bloccato affinché tu non
risolverà i puzzle di destra e sinistra
io penso che tu debba andare prima verso
destra e ma non posso andarci a destra
anzi posso andarci o ciao parco schifo
[Musica]
alti sia complicato chissà se sarebbe
noioso se spiega si il puzzle abbassa
metta top
[Musica]
è la star più famose di tutto il
sottosuolo
la porta che conduce alla prossima area
chiusa quindi ho provato il puzzle a
finire e munizioni continuava a
ripartire
e i miei due colleghi non mi aiutano
sembra che non vogliono andare al lavoro
faccio io spara la neve nevica sposta le
scatole per completare la missione
[Musica]
la nave è mica porto schifo
grazie
ma ha risolto sono sbalordito di essere
un tipo di poi nerd assurdi beh più nell
io o meno bravo
[Musica]
no ho sbagliato è giusto giusto
dirottato però andò al tis eccomi quella
selva sembra proprio che tu non possa
passare ma in quanto scienziata reale o
qualche asso nella manica che l'eroe
database di lazard di robe in terra e lo
disattiverà grazie grande hall fis al
file al faiz sparando nave nemica su ok
mi chiamo stefi incasinato di coli prima
però un aspetto grazie
ora fatto giusto
scout
[Musica]
al fai se pubblicato lo stato va bene lo
spiegherò e basta penso ai per i puzzle
a destra a sinistra sono più difficili
da spiegare ma gli è già risolti
fantastico perché come facevi a
spiegarlo oddio ti prego ti prego ti
prego basta se non ti preoccupare anche
le hostess tema della luce per
illuminare tutto poi farlo senza
chiamarmi a o no che no dai ti prego
benvenuto e bellezza lo show culinario
del sottosuolo
la prova del robot io non ho parole
giuro riscaldate il forno perché abbiamo
una ricetta molto speciale per voi oggi
stiamo per fare una torta per
l'occasione dell'umano aiuterà a
prendere il prendendo gli ingredienti
forza cento un bell'applauso ci servirà
zucchero latte e uova avanti zuccherino
puoi farcela
e uova latte che ha fatto
[Musica]
perfetto ottimo lavoro bellezza
no però schifato è latte zucchero uova o
c'è l'ospedale magnifico attimo come ho
potuto dimenticarlo ma veramente l'hanno
chiamato alla prova del del robot sono
geniali quelli delle traduzioni non è
tanto la clerici ci manca niente più
importante un anima umana orca vacca
[Musica]
vice pronto sani movimento di qualcosa
al momento aspetta un attimo non
potresti fare una non potresti usare un
potresti fare una sostituzione nella
ricetta di usare un altro ingrediente
non umano per quale motivo nel caso in
cui qualcuno sia vegano vegano
[Musica]
onida segnare al file in realtà fortuna
vuole che io abbia un'altra opzione bar
marco vacca un barattolo che è proprio
su due banco della giunta a dirmelo
prima mette solo perché non ti muovi non
vai a prenderlo vado io
io non ho parole giuro
c'è qualcosa che non va tra l'altro il
nostro show una scaletta molto rigida se
non riesce a prendere il barattolino
minuto basta semplicemente tornare al
piano originale quindi ti consiglio
inizia per scalare bellezza non c'è
abbastanza tempo per scalare
fortunatamente potrà avere un piano
quando ho gridato il telefono aggiunto
delle funzioni pellicole nonno e
pulsante con scritto jetpack guarda qua
mi chiama voglio anch'io suo telefono
ecco dovresti avere carburante
sufficiente per raggiungere la cima ora
vai a me mi fa anche il babà beh ragazzi
che cosa sto vedendo come lo spieghi non
posso schivarli e normale o sono io sono
io faccio non posso schivarli questo
scegliero no
sotto come li schivo west
[Musica]
la gara veramente difficile
alla fine non ce l'ho fatta perché non
ti stai muovendo e mi lancia le cose
devo aver messo purtroppo poco
carburante mi dispiace tanto anche
quando è qualcosa come questo io
nonostante tutto adesso c'è il nostro
spazio pubblicità che stai sono
totalmente significa che nessuno ci sta
guardando adesso non è intenzione
riusciti senza una di esse televisiva in
diretta
sembrerebbe che mi hai fregato un'altra
volta grazie a believe the others al fax
alla prossima bellezza ci si vede quindi
alla fine mi ha lasciato andare ha fatto
tutto sto casino per niente rispondo che
noi ce l'abbiamo fatta comunque
continuiamo ad andare avanti
ok però mai
iad chi riempie di determinazione be non
ha voluto medico l'edificio in
lontananza quello è il nucleo alla
sorgente energia di tutto sottosuolo
converte energia geotermica in elettro
magia con quali e dove siamo diretti nel
nucleo c'è un ascensore che porta al
cassero di al gore e eli tu potrai
tornare a casa
schiere ecco ragazzi poi sicuramente
dubito al fis non al file no e al faiz
se la y y si legge al files a meno che i
loro non abbiano storpiato l'inglese se
no anche skyrim si leggerebbe skill im
quindi come papyrus se non si leggerebbe
papirus us gori si legge sgorgo lo so
schivo di cowes gore perché mi fa
ricordare schiere lo so che si chude gol
lo dico a score apposta undying si dice
con line e quindi al fai si regola i a
meno che trovi fox non abbia un suo
inglese quindi siete voi che sbagliate
sono calogero torcia accesa ricordati il
mio nome
va bene calogero
mi spiegate perchè suns e tipo ovunque e
amico come va vuoi comprare un panino
no no cioè non ha spazio in realtà
università e iper i ragni panino tostato
che il turbo al fai ci ha portato via ha
postato un'immagine cena con la mia
dolcezza e le immagini una statuetta di
donna gatto vicino ad una ciotola di
nudo si istantanei shell fico 95 ha
messo una foto
stiamo portando immagini hot ecco io il
medico fico è una foto di papyrus che
mostra i muscoli allo specchio a degli
occhiali del software dei pc pd
muscolosi sono incollati alla sue
braccia anche i bicipiti anno gli
occhiali da sole piro corda si allaccia
al combattimento
[Musica]
chi la guarda
in bra fredda l'attacco dell'api ricorda
cala minchia
non mi ha preso per sta facendo finta di
essere una candela in vita no non eletto
porca vacca ho sbagliato mi interessava
sapere la risposta scalda anzi il
termostato piro che ora comincia a
diventare eccitato
[Musica]
ok quindi devo eccitarlo di più
vai vai scalda scalda che casino
[Musica]
ok scalda
aia porca vacca è difficile
mi ha fatto veramente
prender male al paese pubblicato lo
stato lo scelti con 95 lo scherzo vero
da che parte stava andando raga lo
scherzo l'unico scherzo qui è quanto
fortis e rinvia i muscoli
ciao parola dottoressa al file questo
puzzle e tipo basato sul tempismo vedi
che pulsa tv avanti dovrei prenderli
tutti e tre in tre secondi
ok arco non ci credo mi ha chiamato
nell'ultimo vinto preciso
ok va bene
[Musica]
devo andare in bagno quindi sarò a fk
per un po sono sicura che puoi gestire
questo passo facilmente
una donna ragazzi perché mi fanno un
puzzle ogni tre secondi a minchia mi
cambia dire porca vacca che bordello
no no ho sbagliato
[Musica]
devo arrivare alla fine che sarebbe
dov'è la fine scusate
[Musica]
ma devo arrivare mizzica allora potrebbe
essere veramente difficile però vediamo
[Musica]
no
a yahoo
ma basta far così raga scusate
ok infatti
[Musica]
basta chi è che dice che miu miu miu due
è meglio di miu miu 1 non lo so a me
salva sapere che un giorno il topo
potrebbe scassinare la cassaforte rubare
il formaggio ti riempie di
determinazione salviamo ragazzi dio mio
basta non ne posso più non posso più
sapere se al fai al feisal files
scopriva poi si dice curiosità prima di
concludere almeno poi voglio scoprire
come si dice vorrei scoprirlo ma il
mouse del mio computer è sparito ok
allora anno si dice al tris perché
effettivamente la s vicino alla ypsilon
è vero non ci ho fatto caso come nome al
fis al feed giusto e al fis perché avevo
lettura
pensavo fosse scritto al y es
in quel caso sarebbe stato al files
credo invece non c'erano essere subito
quindi per forza al fis sì per forza sì
sicuramente
quindi sì no forse giusto al fis
prigione quando c'è una ypsilon si è già
ai ripari thank you
e stato proprio bello considerazioni a
me è piaciuto a me è piaciuto veramente
tanto fino adesso dico anche al primo
episodio molto belli in italia non me lo
godo tanto di più perché uno facile
parte che la traduzione fatta benissimo
tipo la prova del robot o geniale
traduzione bellissima degna delle
traduzioni dei giochi tripla x molto
figo ragazzi spero che vi fidiate tutti
dettarmi ne esce
io vi mando bacino ci vediamo domani con
il prossimo video normale e continuerà
la prossima settimana vediamo se
riusciamo a finirlo comunque arrivare
verso la fine
ok italia vi sia piaciuto ragazzi c'era
un pò 6 episodio vado che devo fare la
cacca bella